[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in
the former nfl quarterback star from
notre dame brady quinn works for fox
sports their college football
analyst uh how did you celebrate the
cleveland browns win last night brady
well it's pretty late i've got three
little girls so usually we're exhausted
by it but i was excited about it i
actually uh
i think my wife's mad at me this morning
i kept her up made sure she understood
the historical significance of the
browns winning that playoff game
and i've been in the doghouse ever since
she woke up this morning okay but
explain that to people your former first
round pick with this franchise
it feels like once you're a brown you're
always going to be a cleveland brown the
rest of your life no matter if you play
for another team
well and part of it too for me is i grew
up in a northwest suburb of columbus and
so i
rooted for all the cleveland teams
growing up uh and so getting drafted
there was a dream come true but even
afterwards you know things didn't work
out the way i wanted to or wish they
could have
but i still remained a fan of the team
and obviously i can relate to that fan
base
i think the the struggle when the team
left and moved to baltimore
and then came back for a lot of fans you
know a lot of people in cleveland it's
not the same team as far as what left
and so now we've finally gotten to a
position where
i feel like from an organizational
standpoint they're at a different point
they found a head coach that i know it's
only one year
but i think anyone would it'd be hard to
argue that this team isn't heading in
the right direction obviously
uh baker's playing some of his best
football and really the team's playing
inspired
and that's just something that you know
you didn't see consistently over the
course of really the last two decades
how do the browns beat the chiefs well
uh the the i think the biggest thing
you've got to do uh especially with an
offense that can score the way they do
is you've got to find a way of one
playing really good red zone defense
you got to figure out you can't just
give up the big play for a touchdown you
got to go to that shortened condensed
portion of the field
and figure out a way of getting off
forcing field goals if you can do that
and then on the other side you know i
think you can make the case that yeah
you could try to eat up the clock
and win the time of possession we saw
the colts try to do that this past
weekend versus the bills
but in the end it's not going to win
because if the bills have the ball last
they're going to end up winning the
football game or more often than not be
able to put up enough points once they
do find their rhythm
so i think you almost have to look at
what the raiders did this year when they
beat the chiefs
you've got to be able to go toe for toe
blow for blow with them
and you got to be able to stretch the
field run the football make all those
big plays too and not be scared
offensively
to take some chances so to me it just
comes down to eliminated big plays red
zone defense and offensively
you know taking some risks taking some
chances trying to throw all you can at
the kansas city chiefs defense which
which is improved this year compared to
what they were last year
we'll talk about the national title game
here a moment i'm curious because you
got
breeze and brady and you got rogers you
got roethlisberger
i don't know if a team is more apt to
make a decision
one year early than one year late when
it comes to these older quarterbacks
because everybody wants to have their
mahomes or deshawn watson or josh allen
uh joe burrow justin herbert
like there's so many of these great
talented young players coming out
that i don't know if i'm indie that i go
let me have phillip rivers again or
pittsburgh and let me have ben uh breeze
in new orleans
brady obviously will be back if he wants
to be back but can you see that
philosophy in the nfl
well yeah i could see the philosophy i
mean i think from an economical
standpoint especially as you look in the
next year not necessarily knowing what
the cap is going to be i mean the floor
we know is
175 million uh it could be a little bit
higher than that we'll have to wait and
see but from an economical standpoint
you could understand why they maybe want
to get younger and cheaper but there's a
big risk in that right i mean
is your fan base going to be okay with
having to go through a rebuilding
process potentially
and being patient with that quarterback
position i do think the one thing though
that you look at now with quarterbacks
coming into the league
and it was pretty apparent that tampa
bay buck's washington football team game
is
the ability for a quarterback with
mobility to impact a game
i mean that is now becoming a must for
and requirement for any quarterback
coming into the nfl right now is the
ability to keep the football and run and
pick a few
up a few first downs and challenge the
defense to have to situationally
at a minimum put someone out there who
is responsible for them and we saw
taylor hennicky be able to kind of keep
with the washington football team
in that game in part because of his
athleticism so when you're talking about
the the rivers the roethlisbergers the
brady's the breeze
now those are those are the older age
drop back prototypical
you know drop back quarterbacks you
don't see that so much anymore coming in
the nfl so
i think if you're gonna make that change
yes part of it's economical but the
other thing is
a little bit schematic too with the type
of players that are now coming into the
nfl
is brady quinn working for uh fox uh
sports their college football analyst
tonight's national title game will come
down too
well it's going to come down to whether
or not ohio state
can limit the amount of big plays that
this alabama offense can create i mean
we saw that throughout the course of the
season but in particular in the
semifinal game versus my alma mater and
then on the flip side i think justin
fields
has to have a similar game to what he
had in the semifinal game which was his
best game
as a college quarterback so if he can go
toe-for-toe or
again blow for blow like i mentioned
earlier in the nfl games but if he can
do that
versus this alabama offense i think they
stand a chance but the biggest question
mark right now dan is
you know how big of an impact covid will
have potentially on the d line and how
healthy justin fields is going to be
with that rib injury that he's dealing
with what is alabama's weakness
to me i think it's their defense you
know i think we saw glimpses of that
this year and you've even heard their
head coach nick saban admitted
that this is not you know a game anymore
that's dominated by
you know great defense being able to
stop great offenses you know at times
they can
and i think they've even had to kind of
adapt to uh you know
a bend but don't break at times you know
philosophy of how they're playing
defensively i mean pat certain is going
to take away
one wide receiver for ohio state but
there's plays to be made on the other
side of the field versus the secondary
for alabama
i don't think they have you know as good
of an edge rusher either so
to me if you're looking at you know the
biggest difference right now i think for
bama
it's it's that their defense isn't what
we're accustomed to seeing
and and maybe you want to say that's a
product of their offense being so
explosive
but for me i think it's just more of the
changing of times with college football
the offense has the advantage eventually
the defense will adjust but
we just haven't seen that of late which
running back has to have the bigger game
naji harris or trey sermon trey sermon i
traced sermon just just because i think
you look at
what again not knowing the injury to
fields but you look at how important it
is for the iowa state offense to have
balance
uh that to me is crucial in this game uh
because
i do think certain can take away chris
olave which basically leaves garrett
wilson
and some other targets too but it's a
lot of pressure on garrett wilson to be
able to carry that and owave missed the
big ten championship game versus
northwestern
and howard fields playing that one so uh
that's a concern for me i mean
this pat certain kid he doesn't get
enough credit you know this is going to
be one of the top prospects taking the
next year's draft
and talking to the notre dame coaching
staff before the semifinal game they're
like
if we throw at this kid it's a mistake
okay like ian book made a mistake if
they throw his way
and they did once and it would have been
an interception if certain got his foot
inbounds but he didn't so
um i think you've got to have that
balance you've got to have
the ability to run the football and also
to potentially give their defense a bit
of a break
and not have to have them out on the
field all the time trying to cover
you know the heisman trophy winner in
smith and if waddle plays
but all the other playmakers they have
with naja harris two in the backfield
isn't it amazing that waddle was
considered
the better prospect coming into this
season
devante smith wins the heisman yeah i
mean and give him credit for the way he
steps up
when waddle went down uh you know a lot
of guys sometimes
maybe fade in that or they can't handle
the fact that they're seeing the the
best cornerback they're seeing maybe
more cloud coverage or bracket coverage
at times uh but again going back to that
semifinal game versus notre dame talking
to some of the coaches with that staff
you know one of the things that was
mentioned to me was you don't realize
how fast he is until you get out there
in the field because he's this smooth
long strider
and you think you've got a good angle on
him and next thing you know he slides up
the sidelines or he's running across the
field
and you end up missing a tackle or you
end up not even be able to get a hand on
them so
that's going to be the challenge for
ohio state and look they've got talented
wide receivers
who have speed but they don't move the
same way as that slim reaper as they
call them in devonta smith and the way
he kind of
slides around and smoothly gets yards
after the catch so you know
and that's the thing for ohio state's
defense you know dan when you're
watching the film
from the clemson game i thought they
missed tony elliot a lot
because there was times when they had
the 10 or 20 yard range completion
all game long ohio state was willing to
concede that
but whether it was brennan street or
dabo swinney they didn't want to adapt
or change that game plan
to allow trevor lawrence just to pick
them apart on the sidelines to the
outside
uh that kind of plays the mac jones
wheelhouse and this is
the worst past defense we've ever seen
in the national championship game
in the college football playoff era
giving about 280 plus yards a game so
um it's going to be tough for this
buckeye secretary to stop alabama's
passing attack
i remind people a lot of times that
usain bolt might be the fastest man
in the history of mankind but he didn't
have top end speed
for the first 60 yards for 60 meters
devante smith davonte smith would
probably beat usain bolt in a 60-yard
dash in my opinion
like the the ability to get to a top-end
speed
because bolt once he got to 60 if you
weren't ahead of him
then you weren't going to beat him and i
know that that's you know joey
galloway uh you know an ohio state guy
there's certain guys who have top end
speed like tyreek hill
right tyree kill to me if he's with
usain bolt
would beat him for the first 60 meters
he wouldn't beat him for a hundred but
he beat him for 60 there
these receivers who get you look at me
like i'm crazy you think
you just said usain bolt who may be the
fastest human being in my lifetime
um and so i don't know if i'm gonna
cosign with that i understand what
you're saying though
he's a taller longer strider you know
waddle for example one of the reasons
why he's you know
a better prospect if you will is because
he gets zero to a hundred how about this
devonta smith is a better receiver than
usain bolt would you agree with me on
this
yeah i would hope so but you've been
around guys who have
great speed but they're guys who have
quick
like they get to their top gear quicker
than the other guy does and damonte
smith
that's the difference like when he gets
it out on the side and you go okay you
got him
and then he has that next gear that very
few players have in all
all the sports well that's why i'm
always you know wondering especially
like sean wade for example who's the
best cornerback at ohio state
and you didn't see them do this much in
the semifinal game and they've kind of
limited how much press man-to-man
coverage they play
but usually when you've got a guy who's
like a longer strider like you're
talking about
and doesn't get zero to 100 you know in
a few steps
you'd like to get some hands on them at
the line of scrimmage just drop the
timing
and see if you can stop them before you
ever get started right yeah
and and you don't see that quite as much
and again go back to the semi-final game
watch some of the tape
you'll see them playing eight ten yards
off and willing to concede
some of those passes in front of them as
long as they don't give up a big play
i don't know that that's a recipe for a
success versus alabama and devante smith
because
once he gets going it's not only the
fact that he's got that second gear
he's so smooth in and out of his cuts
you know when he wants to set up a
double move he can really sell it
because of just
the way he's able to cut while still
having that long stride that gate
but then get back up to full speed or
kick into that second gear as you're
talking about
did ohio state offer you a scholarship
they did
oh okay yeah but why'd you pass
oh geez um there was a there's a number
of reasons
you know i thought notre dame uh and
michigan was the other school i was
looking at
um you know notre dame was the best fit
for me one thing that always kind of
laid in the back of my mind
in looking at all three schools was you
know who was the best
nfl quarterback to have come from each
school and obviously michigan's got a
rich history arguably the greatest of
all time and tom brady there's a lot of
others
uh notre dame you could throw that into
that category with joe montana and
theismann and meyer and so many others
uh ohio state you know i would probably
say arch schleister
i mean i'm not sure who else you're
throwing to that category but that was
something that was always going on in
the back of my mind outside of the fact
that you know it was a smaller school
academically it fit more what i was
looking to get out of the education
could you have taken the heat though
brady coming from columbus ohio
going to michigan uh well beauchem
beckler asked me that question
i was with my dad on a recruiting visit
and uh the first thing he said when
i think it was when tom herman was a
linebacker coach at the time he was my
error recruiter
he introduced my father and i and uh
he said that he's from columbus ohio and
he's looking to come to michigan
and beau schoenbecker looks at me and
says are you ready to go in there and
kick those buckeyes ass and my dad my
dad was done he was like
you're going to michigan i was like all
right let's hold on for a second
so uh that was one of the coolest
stories and moments i got to share with
my dad along those recruiting visits
but notre dame gave you a nicer car so
you ended up at south bend
i i wish that was the case you know you
hear about that stuff all the time did
you were you offered
let me take away any school names yeah
what was the best thing you were offered
i i wasn't i wasn't offered anything you
know i i don't know that i look like the
type of guy
that you know and based on my family you
know a hard working middle class
and like i don't know if they were
walking into our household saying like
hey what do you need
um and plus like my parents would have
never accepted that
you know i i was i was somebody had a
job throughout the course of my time at
notre dame
i worked at the cadence center there on
campus and the uh the office of news and
information
in the golden dome just to have a little
extra grocery money gas money
uh and and just a little money to get
around i used to take the lineman
to this italian restaurant that an
all-you-can-eat buffet on the south side
of town
and i think it was like eight bucks a
pop and we basically on thursday nights
go
watch football and see who can eat the
most chicken parm cutlets
oh they lost money on you guys when you
guys came in
all you could eat for eight dollars a
pop i was i was
out eating ryan harris you can ask ryan
harris he used to call me a snake
for basically waiting all day to eat
dinner
just to out-heat him that night uh
great to talk to you have fun tonight we
appreciate your time as always brady
always a pleasure guys have a great day
that's brady quinn former cleveland
browns quarterback